every cell in the human body needs
energy to survive and do its different
functions if we're talking about a brain
cell it needs energy to
keep stimulating other brain cells and
sending on signals and messages if it's
a muscle cell it needs energy to
contract they need energy just to do the
basic functions of a cell and the place
that they get that energy from or the
primary source of that energy is from
glucose
glucose and glucose is a simple sugar if
you were to actually taste glucose it
would taste sweet and glucose gets
delivered to cells through the
bloodstream so this right here i'm
drawing some blood that's passing by a
cell maybe the blood is going in that
direction over there and inside the
blood let me draw some small
some small glucose molecules
passing by
and so in an ideal situation when the
cell needs energy glucose will enter the
cell so glucose will enter the cell
unfortunately it's not that simple for
the great majority of cells in the human
body the glucose won't enter by itself
it needs the assistance of a hormone or
a molecule called insulin so let me
label all of these this right here
is glucose
and it needs insulin so let me draw
insulin as these magenta molecules right
over here
so that over there that is insulin
in
sulin and the surface of these cells
they have insulin receptors on them and
i'm just drawing very simplified
versions of them kind of a place where
these magenta circles can can attach
can bind and what happens is in order
for the glucose to be taken up by the
cell
insulin has to kind of
attach to these receptors which unlocks
the channels for glucose in order for
the glucose to go in
insulin has to bind to the insulin
receptors
and then once that happens then the
glucose can be taken up
can be taken up by the cell
now unfortunately things don't always
work as planned so let me draw a couple
of scenarios here so once again let me
draw my very simple version of a cell
and
let me draw the bloodstream going by
right over here
and then let me draw the glucose in the
bloodstream
so i have my glucose floating by
and then i have my insulin receptors my
insulin receptors on the surface of a
cell
now the first thing that could go wrong
here is what if the body does not
produce insulin insulin is produced in
the pancreas what happens if the
pancreas is not producing insulin
properly so no
no
insulin
well in this situation since there's
nothing to bind to these receptors the
glucose channels won't be opened up and
the glucose will not be able to enter
into the cell
and this situation is type 1 diabetes
type
type 1
diabetes where you've got glucose so in
theory you have energy and you have
properly functioning insulin receptors
but you just don't have insulin to kind
of unlock the gates for the glucose for
the glucose to actually go into the cell
the other scenario that you could
imagine happening let me draw the cell
again
so there's my cell
and let me draw the blood flowing past
the cell
and once again obviously this is just
one of trillions of cells in the human
body we have an estimated 10 to 100
trillion cells so this is a very simple
diagram but hopefully it gets the point
across
so once again let me
draw some glucose floating by
let me draw some insulin receptors on
the cell
so insulin receptor there may be an
insulin receptor right over there and
let's say we even have some insulin so
we are our pancreas is producing insulin
and and putting it into our bloodstream
so it's there to be used but a situation
can arise where
the receptors are not working properly
or we've become insensitive or or
desensitized to insulin so
d
desensitized
desensitized receptors
so in this situation you have maybe
sometimes maybe it might be the insulin
is hard to bind or even if it does bind
it's not working function properly
so the glucose will not enter the cell
and so in either one of the let me
already wrote desensitized so in either
one of these scenarios let's just think
in a very broad level i'm not going to
go into the details of the actual
therapy for these for these diseases of
how it can be cured oh and i didn't even
name the second one the second one right
here as you can imagine if this appears
type 1 diabetes this down here is type 2
diabetes type
type 2
type 2 diabetes now the way the simple
way that or i don't want to say it's
necessarily simple but the way that you
can
manage type 1 diabetes is you can inject
insulin the only problem here is it's a
big one though is that there's no
insulin in the bloodstream everything
else is working properly so over here we
can inject insulin
we can inject it
and then you'll have insulin to attach
to the receptors and then the glucose
can be
processed properly type 2 diabetes
there's kind of multiple lines of attack
one thing that you can do there are
actually drugs that
attempt to kind of re-sensitize your
insulin receptors you can also do that
with a combination of lifestyle changes
that makes the makes your body
i guess more sensitized to to sugar
or you can even and if things get severe
enough you can add insulin just like you
would do in type 1 diabetes and you
could say wait i already have insulin
here why would i add more insulin well
remember we're not kind of
the the cells can process insulin but
they're desensitized they would need
more insulin in order to kind of uptake
the same amount of glucose so if you add
insulin you could possibly have enough
enough of a trigger that the glucose can
actually be taken up but there's
multiple lines of attack here and
usually the first one are giving drugs
that help
hopefully make re-sensitize you or make
you less desensitized to the actual
insulin
and so the last thing i just want to
think about a little bit is well what
happens if you didn't do this well
there's two major problems here
obviously your cells can't function if
it's not taking up glucose so your cells
will have
no energy and another problem if you if
you weren't to manage either one of
these types of diabetes is that sugar
once it gets to enough if it gets too
high enough concentrations in the blood
it can actually cause a lot of damage so
sugar
sugar can cause damage
damage to the body so you don't want
either of these things happening you
want your cells to have energy and you
don't want to have too much sugar
flowing in your blood and causing damage
to your body